what was it actually like I'm I'm just
curious this is obviously your first
time being the lead in a movie like this
what do you what actually surprised you
about the process I mean it was yeah it
was definitely the first time that I'm
leading like this but also I got to work
with Adam and it was just the two of us
every day I think what surprised me the
most is how
is how
I don't know I guess how important
chemistry is and Adam and I bonded on
multiple levels with you know the
weather and the conditions we went
through and and also just how we have
very similar sense of humor like Adam
and I had the driest most sarcastic
humor possible and a lot of people don't
know when we're joking but I always know
when he's joking he always knows when
I'm joking so chemistry is is really
important for sure and just really
living in the environment and really
understanding your character is
incredibly important when when you're
doing something like this and I spent a
lot of time with KOA and making sure I
understand her fully and completely when
it comes to her body language to how she
says things how she walks and runs and
everything
um understanding your character
very well was important when you were
looking at the filming schedule what was
the day you had circled like this is
either going to be the best day of the
shoot or the day I'm gonna effing hate
yeah yeah so I was really
um
I was dreading the day
it was I think it was like Midway to the
end of filming and it was the big scene
that it was one of my audition scenes
it's a big turning point for KOA and um
it's a big emotional day and I think I
was just dreading it because it's been
so like suspensed up like throughout the
first day of filming we were always
talking about the scene how important it
is how much of a of a turning point it
is and when the day came I was like okay
like this is your time it's time to do
it like you've been dreading it but if
you it's time to go and it was a really
emotional draining day
um it was everything I thought it was
going to be but
it worked out and I got it and I
persevered and then I went through that
day and the day that I was most excited
for I want to say
it was probably the this wasn't even
filming this this was pre-production it
was the day they they decided to chop my
hair off because I had hair like this
length when I when I first started you
know the process of the film and they
were like we're actually gonna chop your
hair off and I was like okay like Yay
let's do it I was so down I was like cup
bangs diet black shaved like I was like
do whatever you want to do
um but they ended up just going with the
Timeless Bob look and I was so excited
for that day I was like cut it shorter
cut it shorter just do whatever you want
and they were like calm down calm down
and I was like okay okay that was
definitely the day I was most excited
for I'm just about out of time with you
but I am actually really looking forward
to the Barbie movie I think I think it's
going to be fantastic this is just my
gut feeling uh what can you tease people
about your role in the film and what you
are excited for people to see I am so
excited for people to see everything
that they just are not expecting the
people they're not expecting the looks
they are not expecting
um from the leaks you've seen on Twitter
and Instagram and everything is just
smallest little amount that you could
possibly think of Greta is so genius and
she and she made this beautiful film I'm
so excited to be a part of it and my
character fits in somehow some way can't
say because it'll spoil something but
just know it's really exciting and I
think it's a it's a Timeless really fun
movie so excited for that to come out on
that note I gotta go
um congrats on everything and um wish
you nothing but the best